welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about the tiny
things that live inside us forever
hey I'm referring of course in the
quantum realm and the MCU hi I'm Erik
Bosse here with Tummie Bechtold oh you
don't and I'm doing good Eric how are
you I'm hanging in I'm hanging out
hanging in
we're both missing Philip but so back up
again he's with us speaking of things
that are always inside you oh my god a
little bit of Philip is inside each one
of us you got to stop taking those pills
that he gives me you don't know what he
puts it on Phil tells they're great
they're blue cheese sorry watch of
ant-man the wasp a movie that I very
much enjoy because it explored to date
the most explained in confusing aspect
of the MCU the quantum realm you know
with its inconsistent logic and rules
for how fast you age it it it's
wonderful so let's talk about this
episode Tommy what's the big question
alright get yourself ready the big
question today is how does the quantum
realm work exactly
why does Janet age differently from
Scott and are there any rules to it or
anything goes wild wild west scenario it
seems like a bit of that Tommy because I
have studied the MC quantum realm enough
to justify a doctoral thesis at this
point I think I should get honorary
degrees from every University for the
amount of freaking research I've done I
agree I have there's got to be some way
we could get you honored well I have
concluded as a result of my research
that the quantum realm is Marvel's big
gaping plot hole they just keep throwing
[ __ ] into to pull off even crazier
[ __ ] and we just don't question it
because it's called quantum as if it
matters so a bit of history on the
quantum realm it was first of course
introduced in ant-man when Hank Pym
described it as it means that you would
enter a quantum realm what does that
mean it means that you would enter a
reality where all concepts of time and
space become irrelevant as you shrink or
all eternity
at the time though we should remember
that Hank only had a limited
understanding of the quantum realm that
was just his warning of it but really
it's
are more complex than he even realized
at that point why is it called the
quantum realm
well the quantum realm was the MCU name
for what's known as the Mike reverse or
microworld subatomic and the Marvel
Comics
it's revisited a couple times it's kind
of given different names but they had to
call it quantum realm because in 2015
the Marvel Mike reverse was the property
of different studios some believe it was
owned by Paramount because they had the
micronauts or it might have been a Fox
property because of its association with
Fantastic Four microworld is often
visited by the Fantastic Four and their
related characters in the comics it's
like one of their settings and they use
the term quantum because screenwriters
love to pay Stanford nerds to come in
and consult on their movies and they
here where it's like quantum and they
think oh sure what's called that and
it's paying for consultants like
whatever I get to buy Alexis with my
Disney buddy and no one questions it
remember the movie Quantum of Solace
what the hell did that title mean it
meant confusing movie title to me I had
no no grasp of that at all like that
movie seemed like Daniel Craig was
trying to figure out what quantum means
the whole time
well the concept as described in the
ant-man movies is that once you shrink
to a subatomic level the uncertainty of
quantum physics makes the impossible
possible so like time is no longer
measurable phase-shifting now is
possible and of course there are time
vortexes at a lot of time-travel we'll
get to those but we get a nice
clarification and dr. strange so strange
briefly passes through what is actually
the quantum realm during that movies
magical mystery tour sequence and the
ancient ones voiceover calls it an
example of some benevolent and
life-giving so this would suggest that
the quantum realm is not just a smaller
plane of existence that spans everywhere
in our universe rather it's like a
separate parallel dimension to our
dimension that's just accessible through
extreme subatomic shrinking so it's like
when you shrink that far you go through
like a portal and now you access this
other dimension that exists alongside us
okay don't say okay as if you get that
because I don't get it I don't think any
of us really get it you know what it
made me think of when you learn about
cells animal cells and plant cells and
how they have different molecular walls
and like how certain cells on a plant
are spaced further apart so things can
move in and out I'm sure that that has
nothing to do with it but very briefly I
felt smart so go ahead and leave in the
comments why I'm wrong why would I just
said makes no sense see Tommy and I are
both applying episodes of the Magic
School Bus to this where they were able
to shrink small enough and walk in
between cells and ride white blood cells
around yeah that's what happened they
would suffocate immediately from the air
molecules function differently all of
them would have blood clots Ralphie in
Arnold wouldn't last five seconds
so the reason I brought up the sorcerer
supreme is because they're actually the
one guru source that we can really trust
them see you like remember an endgame
the time-travel logic in that movie is
all over the place it's self
contradictory it's coming from sources
like Pym tech from stark tech Bruce
Banner tries to figure it out none of
them could really agree on how it really
works until Bruce Banner talks to the
ancient one and she gives him that nice
handy timeline this is what happens when
you branch reality in between the two of
them they give us a pretty good
understanding of how time travel works
so that is basically Marvel saying okay
you know what the scientists in our
universe are all coming from different
points but the Wizards are smarter than
the scientists so listen to the Wizards
Tommy you asked are there rules and I
think we can boil down five rules of the
quantum realm so far in the MCU so let's
let's run through those rules all right
rule number one is you have to access
the quantum realm with Pym tech with Pym
particles so entry and exiting from the
realm basically has two components it
needs a quantum tunnel that is fueled by
Pym particles that are triggered by the
pilot by the person going into the realm
and you can stumble in the quantum room
by accident
not a good idea to stumble it drunk off
the beach or something you're gonna want
to know you could luck out by just like
loosely shoving a Pym disc in your belt
buckle across my fingers like Scott Lang
did to get out of it but that's
ill-advised it's an exception to the
rule we think only the charmingly
befuddled Paul Rudd could could fall
ass-backwards into that solution exactly
we do need Pym particles that is the
magic fuel that allows you to access
this and it really any era of it because
we saw cap using 1970 pin vials so
clearly those things are not enough of a
beta prototype they they work they help
you get in and out and we also continue
that Pym particles can be replicated and
reverse engineered so in in game the
2014 era Thanos steals good nebulas Pym
vial but he's able to get his whole
fleet and army to the present day how
did he do that well the movies
filmmakers were like they can reverse
engineering there's hard enough
he's a 3d printer to make more of it
call obsidian is just in the lab like
like a montage like walking on sunshine
is playing yes he's like it blows up in
his face have any mozz just like you
idiot
[Music]
so rule number two the quantum realm has
what I call tricky physics in all kinds
of ways but really the physical
properties are unstable and uncertain
they're applying things like the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle and in
quantum mechanics that once you're
trying to measure things on that
subatomic level they don't always follow
our normal physics particles can appear
in the same place at the same time you
can't really measure it so the way they
apply them see is that bodies and
particles can kind of shift in and out
of phases of matter like the character
of ghosts she got hit with a blast of
energy from the quantum realm and then
she gained this power of her body phase
shifting through surfaces you know like
you she can turn into a ghost or like a
projection of herself and that ends up
like making her unstable and they have
to try to fix her by the end of the
movie but it is worth noting that based
on Hank and Janet's brief time together
in the quantum realm it seems that
gravity exists and some version of air
is breathable mmm which doesn't make
sense Tommy because they're between
atoms and electrons you need o to
molecules to be able to breathe and
oxygenate your blood so you don't
immediately suffocate and die that's
this might that's gonna be my answer to
anything of way above my intelligences
just reverse engineering and anyone in
the comments saying we're thinking too
hard about it you know shame on you
first off this is the big question is a
show where we think too hard about
everything we have important work to do
but also if they didn't want us to
overthink it they shouldn't have had
scientists spend the whole movie
explaining the functionality of all this
yeah if it was just something like that
we're using Asgardian sorcery it's our
Asgardian science or the the science of
the Sorcerer's supreme we buy it as just
magic I would even say like wakanda's
science is just more mystical in a way
yeah we're just more willing to suspend
our disbelief but if you have
scientists who spend all their time in a
lab being the authorities on this of
course we're gonna question and get
confused
agreed rule number three Tommy this is
the big one time how does time work well
time does exist in the quantum realm it
flows normally because Janet Van Dyne
was down there and she aged 30 years I'm
not the same woman I was 30 years ago
Henry but why did Scott only perceive it
as five hours and went five years into
the future well it's because within the
quantum realm are separate holes called
time vortexes they're separate these are
what the avengers used in the time highs
now just quantum realm in general but
within the quantum realm separate things
called the time vortex is we know
they're separate from Janet's warning to
Scott in the post-credits Angie said and
don't get sucked into a time vortex we
won't be able to save you so in other
words while you're down there in the
broader quantum realm don't fall into
this separate thing called a time vortex
wasn't really clarified an endgame but
that's what Scott did he spent five
hours in there towards the end of that
five hours he slipped into a time vortex
and then that savior rat reactivated the
man tech to pull them back out save your
rat this is my favorite new mutant all
the save your rat comics even the weird
ones even the todd mcfarlane issues
precious to me so time vortexes are like
I call them time slides they're like
different water slides you can dip into
and you never know some water slides are
terrifying straight down others are the
YB kind you can go on with a friend an
inner-tube
maybe try and catch a smooch if it's a
lovely lady or depending on your
preference those tunnels are dark you
don't know you're hopped on the raft way
I just pucker up and let it rip that's
what I always say cuz you did a single
rider line and because you wanted to
skip that line your friends don't want
to go with you see hopefully they
partner or lady with you yeah we I went
to wild waters I know that works water
parks are a great place to take a lover
I've always said that also a great place
to like injure yourself and go into a
lazy river full of pee a lot of urine in
the water a lot of rashes on the arm
yeah so Janet was there for three
decades what did she do how did she
survive that long well that brings us to
rule number four the quantum realm must
sustain life
so the quantum roam consists of these
quantum healing particles is what Janet
used to repair ghosts phase-shifting and
that might be what the ancient one meant
by benevolent and life-giving it's
possible that Janet never needed to eat
or consume anything for nourishment
maybe her hunger was just satisfied with
these healing particles that nourished
her life force for this full time also
Janna described her survival as a kind
of evolution to hank pym suggesting that
her sustained exposure to the quantum
room energy changed her DNA
adaptation is part of it but some of it
is evolution you're not to get all you
know biology 101 with you but
technically that would be adaptation
evolution requires several generations
of reproducing species to pass on their
competitive traits to their offspring
but you know marvel has ruined would
implode actual revolutionaries evolution
doesn't happen within one living
creature over the course of their
lifetime but whatever
also huge detail probably the biggest
clue that has not been explored and
hopefully will be explored innate may
have three there was a city there's a
freaking city hidden in the background
of the quantum realm as Janet and Hank
leave it it's hard to spot but you can
see skyscrapers that appear to be in
some kind of dome bubble now presumably
this civilization was the source of
Janet's new clothes like she was wearing
a cloak and a staff work to get those
she didn't go down in there with them no
and presumably she's already told Hank
all about this like maybe when they
showed up at Tony Stark's funeral the
camera just didn't linger on them long
enough first off I couldn't grab the
camera and be like this is how I lived
she doesn't shut up about it she's like
did you gotta go to the city and
friendly Hank Tim's just like shut up
shut up I can't go to see I can't go
those follow-up questions it's insane
that they were not included in the final
activate me in the West the final act
should have just been everyone sitting
around Michelle Pfeiffer in their liver
in her room and she's like okay so yeah
year 4 is when I got that staff yeah I
got it on sale I pull in a bone out of a
turtle grade yes it doesn't make sense
no now in the comics microworld does
actually contain civilizations and
planets even dr. doom lives down there
for a period he rules the planet called
mir wood there's the lizard men of the
planet talk that are down there the
Fantastic Four team up with Hank Pym day
later tune with Scott
they ventured into it there's villains
like Baron Carson and psycho man coming
from there there's a lot of people
hanging out down there one theory that
I've seen I think is interesting is that
the ruler of that hidden city could have
been Kang the Conqueror given its
proximity to Tommy's timeslice maybe
he's like the seasoned navigator and
he's like ah you want to go into the
time vortex will you well I know hey
this slide will take you out by the lazy
way this slide will take you out by the
entrance so if you want to go because
you ripped your bathing suits you can
get a new one at the gift shop chicken
fingers and fries are half off on
Thursdays he's a king the Congress is a
lifeguard yeah this is a summer job but
he's he's getting lots of tail his name
cake just says direct furthermore on
this point of life in the quantum realm
wildlife does exist in the quantum realm
tardigrades these little water bears and
Tommy this doesn't make any sense
because tardigrades are real biological
creatures yes but their size they're way
bigger in real life they range from 0.1
millimeter to 1.5 millimeter they're
visible with the naked eye they're not
subatomic presumably here's my theory to
justify this
I think Janet when she was first shrunk
and went down to the quantum realm in
the 80s she also grabbed a couple
tardigrades with her as she was
shrinking maybe through some Pym disks
on those handfuls
tardigrades yes she was just trying to
latch onto something and they shrunk
down with her and then they now made it
and populated the quantum realm it's
like their as their cattle charge agreed
and our final rule the quantum realm can
affect and be affected by events in our
dimension and vice versa
so I mentioned had the flow of time is
the same unless you go to a time vortex
well Janet was able in real time to
communicate with Scott planting a memory
in his mind and he just thought it was
like a strange dream but then later she
like inhabited his body putting in a 10
in his head like Patrick Swayze had
Whoopi Goldberg and ghost you in danger
the Hank Pym and it was just this weird
thing but that was all in real time like
your next-door neighbor putting their
mind and yours they're parallel also we
found out finally that Scott Lang was
vulnerable to Thanos's snap he just got
lucky
according to the Russos he was lucky
that he wasn't one of the ones dusted by
the snap but he could have disintegrated
and really do you think about the whole
universe was lucky because Scott's
survival in the corner room was the
thing that led to our discovery of these
time slides that allowed them to steal
the Infinity stones from the past and
reverse everything so who's in
conclusion Tommy the quantum realm I
believe is just a randomness land that
so far just exists to justify whatever
crazy [ __ ] MC wants to do it'd be
fine if they embrace the like magic and
sorcery side of it but they keep trying
to use science it's science to make it
make sense and really they're like
moving the goalposts constantly on those
scientific limits and what the rules are
on it so instead of a cool cavern of
mystery that it could be currently it's
just like a plot hole factory that just
clogs our mailbox with questions which
we're happy to answer which gives us a
purpose which I appreciate it reminds me
of when you have a generally clean
apartment but there is that one closet
that you've just said screw it and you
throw everything into so there's like
cookware Sporting Goods old t-shirts a
bowling ball all of your files from your
taxes for five years like there's just
no rhyme or reason for your sketch team
that you bought for that one month you
needed a knight of armor chest plate
that you thought you would get three
uses out of it never got another one my
kylo Ren mask and massive sword that I
gave you that I have I never returned to
recover I think I still have it I keep
trying to find you to give it back it's
not your fault it's my fault completely
I'm like this part I was thinking with
the negs I needed the kylo Ren mask for
a bit but I didn't need it when I say
need it an idea occurred to me for five
seconds where I was like oh I could have
my roommate send me my kylo Ren mask and
do a sketch but I don't this is
something we can solve off the air and
another time but I just no bags I'm like
oh I've had Eric just lugging around a
sword years probably a year and a half
now oh my god insane anyway
we interrupt this program to bring you a
special report I don't know what's real
or not just like you don't know whether
it's real dead bolt in the front pocket
is an actual wallet or not because you
got a ridge by the way thanks to the
ridge wallet for sponsoring this episode
the ridge helps you carry what you need
every day from their flagship Ridge
wallet to their portable
charging commuter backpack they want you
to make the most out of what you're
bringing with you the ridge wallet is
made out of military-grade materials
like titanium carbon fiber there's a
clean stylish design it is chainsaw
proof yes
someone tried to fight this with the
chainsaw and then last this one is their
matte cobalt wallet they do have other
colors include some very flashy Tiki
designs it is light it's strong if
you're wearing jeans like I always do
and you're running through the rain the
blue from your jeans just blends them
with the blue with the cobalt all right
thing whoa breach makes it easy to buy
with free shipping and free returns and
a lifetime guarantee
it's got 30,000 five-star reviews so you
know they're doing something right they
also have great backpacks and travel
bags with RFID blocking pockets and
optional device charging batteries get
10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to Ridge
comm slash new rock stars that's rich
calm slash new rock stars and use the
code new rock stars find the link in the
video's description our feature
presentation all right let's move on to
some more bite-sized questions at
Tommy's gonna take for us Tommy you
ready I'm ready I'm hungry I'm hungry
for knowledge
see Aaron Mike asks why did kapda Tasha
and Scott go to Tony Stark first an
in-game when if they recruited Bruce
Banner first they might have had better
luck convincing Tony you know Eric
that's a great question as always we're
not when I'm posed with fantastic
questions I go to the Internet take the
spin now you in with techno set you go
on sensing on the Internet
and I had come up with a very nuanced
answer about Captain America and Iron
Man playing count of four dimensional
chess with each other and I kept America
trying to go to the best out of Tony
Stark but in the end the good old
Internet provides us with the actual
answer to this question which is in an
interview with the screenwriters Markus
and McFeely they simply said they needed
to go to Tony Stark first so that he
could refuse the call and kind of reject
the Avengers which he was responsible
for originally assembling only to be
reminded of the great loss by seeing a
picture of his surrogate son spider-man
Peter Parker and feel the compulsion to
both problem-solve and rejoin the
Avengers and so I think yeah it just
comes down to screenwriting 101 you know
the hero needs to have some adversity
before seizing his ultimate destiny and
a crisis of faith if you will and Tony
Stark was questioning his place in the
universe and it's way more interesting
to have him initially say I'm out I'm
not helping anymore I'm just gonna
accept the fact that half of the
universe is gone leveling yourself with
grief a situation of loss where you just
kind of the acceptance they say is often
important with it so I'm metaphysical
the Universal snapped Australian half of
all life I think the acceptance of loss
can be a little more pliable than if you
know your cat gets hit by a fire truck
or something like that's probably you
probably not going to be able to get him
back with a time slide as much as you
want specially when it was fire men who
hit it their unimpeachable they're just
so hunky everyone that can get away with
suspenders and no shirt underneath mr.
November was driving Oh could I bring a
lawsuit against it I'm not even mad I'm
actually just kind of happy to get a
chance to talk to him all right so yeah
so the answer just comes down to a
technical decision made by the
screenwriters and you know what yeah I
think that's a great answer and
sometimes characters just aren't at the
top of their intelligence they're just
so excited to try to reach out to the
first person they'd want to talk to you
not really thinking of like the strategy
of the game plan of which order they're
gonna talk to people
characters are human you know they're
not they don't always have any gods eye
view of everything you want to run and
tell Dad Tony is like you Tony is like
the papa
he's the Philip of that group you know
they want to run to tell their father
get his both approval of the mission
and participation so yeah next bite-size
MIT honneur mitten 619 PV asks what
happens if Deadpool or Wolverine are
decapitated this is a fun one
where's well you gotta remember two
things Deadpool regenerates Wolverine
yah heels
so in Deadpool 2 when he screams
stricken over his gorgeous girlfriend's
assassination Deadpool attempts to
explode himself up and we see his head
completely detached from everything else
including a middle finger and then of
the next scene he's he's healed and he
has regrown in the comics his head gets
cut off all the time a baby's body will
dangle down from it if you decapitate
Deadpool it's like Deadpool you like
clipping a finger now for him my
fingernails growing back so he
unfortunately if you're looking to kill
Deadpool you're gonna have to get more
creative decapitation because he will
regenerate okay so he's like a starfish
like patrick Star no losers booth but
Wolverine is a little more complicated
because there doesn't seem to be a
consensus you know Wolverine has healing
factors in civil war literally he gets
burned all the way down to his
adamantium skeleton and then regenerates
from just a skull and bones but he never
gets decapitated in another I believe
Ultimate Marvel comic book they have his
head literally hanging by like a couple
of muscle fibers and he heals so it
appears as though they're suggesting if
he were to become completely decapitated
he would actually die but they never
proved that and on another issue of
Ultimate Marvel Nick Fury explains to a
different dimensions Wolverine that in
his dimension they actually cut
Wolverines head off and deprived it of
oxygen and all the head did was go into
stasis until they supplied it with
oxygen again and then it began to live
and succeed on its own no he won't
regrow a body but if you cut his head
off it will continue to stay a lot so
there's not a clear-cut answer it
appears as though the majority of the
comic books would have you believe it if
its head is separated from his body he
will die but there are literal Marvel
series that have it explained that if
you kind of set off you want so it's
kind of one of those things where pick
which run of a Wolverine character
you're getting
and roll the dice I'm whether or not
you'd cut his head off I wouldn't mess
with him either way cuz I love he's
Canadian yeah I think the answer to that
one is Deadpool obviously is is okay
because he can always regenerate
yes Wolverine now that he's gonna
probably be joining the MCU a pg-13
world and isn't Deadpool who gets an
extension for him probably won't have
such gruesomeness happen to him anyway
alright moving on to our third and final
bite-sized antisocial kid X asks would
Tony Stark have died when he snapped
against Thanos if he was wearing his
Hulkbuster armor this is a great
question and this was a lot of fun to
look up because at first I was really
like yeah this is kind of like the Jerry
Seinfeld why not make the whole airplane
out of the black box it's the only thing
that survives a crash
why don't they build the whole plane out
of the black box I mean that's right if
Hulk can snap the gauntlet and use the
time stones and not be destroyed with
the Hulkbuster but there's earlier to
remember is the Hulk Buster is not a
replica of Hulk it's a something meant
to battle Hulk it's supposed to
replicate the indestructible nature of
Hulk but from physical tangible forces
getting hit getting blasted with
missiles and bullets and being able to
fall from great heights being able to be
thrown up against you know immovable
objects but it's not immune to gamma
radiation it's it's not it's not
lead-lined that would make it way way
too heavy even with hydraulic lifts and
the things that make the Iron Man suit
able to you know probably way more than
Tony Stark can still fly and Laura to
actually build an entire Hulkbuster suit
out of lead it would just be completely
impractical it would be like having
Incredible Hulk with concrete around his
ankles that actually somehow stopped him
and that he wouldn't breakthrough and
Hulk himself says he's smart Hulk when
he snaps
everyone back he says I was literally
made for this you know cuz he can never
get a radiation he's made from gamma
radiation so the reason the Hulk suit
would not save 30 sarkis maybe he would
litt have lived longer maybe he would
have sustained less damage but
ultimately I believe he would have had
what would be a lethal dose of gamma
radiation and even if he had lived more
than just a day it wouldn't have been
more than a month beyond that that he
would have lit so I think
could have extended his life but he
would not be able to survive we saw
Chernobyl we know the timeline after you
get exposed to that stuff no God please
no Tony should be happy he died as
quickly as he did I think for merciful
deaths that was probably easier yes for
sure all right well thank you everyone
for somebody those questions we have
time for one more a mailbag question
let's see here we go what is the worst
job or gig that you have I've you know I
have really had so many jobs in my life
I started working when I was 14 and from
that point on I've usually had two or
three jobs most of them have been
fantastic but I really think my first
job ever was my worst job I worked on a
farm
the hours were crazy it was like 5:00
a.m. till whenever they decided you
could go I made four dollars and 55
cents an hour I didn't get a work permit
from Wegmans the grocer the grocery
store that would allow me to work as a
14 year old my parents had a sign and my
job was literally bagging 10-pound bags
of potatoes weighing them making sure
they were exactly ten pounds as if I had
any control over how to make a potato
that without cutting it way less than is
it so basically like somehow Jen going
in you know a dozen potatoes or whatever
to me to ten pound bag of potatoes all
while being yelled at by the absolutely
insane owner of the farm also the
migrant workers that were far ahead of
me and I've been working there for years
I just didn't like anyone coming in let
alone like a little white kid so slick I
I was fighting a real uphill battle now
it's not little but you know I just
remember I did it for way too long way
way like months and months and months
and finally one day just getting sick of
getting yelled at I took a bag of
potatoes and I tossed them at the guy
who was in charge of me sealed off and
that he caught them and I ran while he
was so surprised that they were there I
ran up the front door and I ran about a
half a mile all the way to where I lived
away from the farm and I was like so
sure that like the cops were going to
come as if there would be a
the real reaction like I hid like I was
a crouched in my living room like in a
defensive pose like when the cops burst
through I'm gonna fight my way out and
you know it was true insanity but that
job really broke me mentally he so I I
remember running away and I remember my
both my being like my parents are gonna
kill me
and then both be like you should have
quit that months ago they're like we
were really impressed that you stuck
with it but like what a horrible jobs
I love how parents like they know they
know that we're taking these [ __ ] jobs
but they just kind of let us discover
how bad it is ourselves so that you know
it builds character and we learn to to
make different choices for sure and it
also taught me that I could really if
the circumstances around the job
mattered enough I could put up I mean I
put up with some real stinkers of jobs
in LA like horrible horrible bosses I've
worked for for production companies that
are just psychopaths and I'm like
nothing is worse than bagging potatoes
I'm sitting at a desk at least I'm at a
computer desk occasionally checking
Instagram in between these I can create
crazy you know entitled rants from these
people like nothing is as bad as that
manual labor all day so mine is very
very similar my worst job was my first
job and I was like around the same age
as 15 or 16 and I worked at a Boy Scout
summer camp which I took the job because
I had friends who had done it the
previous summer they're like it's so
great you're your camp counselor you
you're like king of this world everyone
else is your age and if your Boy Scouts
you could also to take merit badge
classes and get Eagle Scout faster and
the pay isn't great but like you're
getting food it's like you're just
camping all summer it's great I made the
mistake of working in the dining hall oh
just the one job there that actually
sucks yeah you don't get to hang out
you're constantly working from like 6:45
in the morning through like 9:30 at
night and you get paid a day rate and
it's [ __ ] I think we got paid a week
rate and I like I had that thing when
you get your first job and you don't get
your actual first paycheck until like
the pay period later it's like I've been
working for a month and I have nothing
to show for it and when you finally get
it it's like here's a hundred and eighty
dollars yes
and then you go to the payroll guy he's
like that's what it is we actually made
a mistake it was only supposed to be
$160 yeah he just tears off a quarter of
the cheque but I remember like you the
people who I work for we're all just
kind of crazy because they were all
overworked too and they just picked
these petty battles at one point I was
cutting carrots and I let it roll and it
like cut my finger but I saw I had to
work the shift of working this pressure
steam washer yeah I was like I'm
handling it was supposed to be sanitary
things and I have a bloody cut in my
finger I'm doing my best to wrap it up
put a glove around it but like steamy
water is leaking down to the cup at one
point I lifted up my glove and it's just
like a blood balloon around my hand
there's like the other guys wanted to
work the ship they're like you [ __ ] it's
your turn boss you still have to do it
to me the scariest part of the job was
the first week actually wasn't that bad
because they closed down the camp just
to open up to a couple of latter-day
saint troops there's just like three
different Mormon troops of the nicest
sweetest kids in the world they cleaned
up after themselves they were polite to
when they had to hand back their trade
to the washroom if they didn't want a
food they wouldn't have you put it on
their tray because they didn't want to
make the extra mess for you in the world
and I'm like this is great if this is
how it is all summer it's not that bad
of a gig week two though everything
changed right away and our dining hall
director pulled me aside she's like boss
you're gonna have to set up the cereal
bar in morning and you do not look them
in the eye outside the window I said why
not she's like you just do what I said
boy so I go out there it's like 7:00 in
the morning I'm just blurry eyed and I'm
putting up a cereal and the milks and
everything and in the corner of my eye I
see an adult leader of one of the groups
with us to go coffee mug oh god he's
he's just staring at me and I'm like I'm
not supposed to look at him but then I
make the mistake of looking over and he
points at his mug because he wants
normally like each of the troops are
supposed to be brought in at a specific
order based off of like
and things like that and he wanted
special treatment to be brought in early
to get coffee so that he could wake up
enough to wait 20 minutes to be brought
in and we're not allowed to do that and
she didn't tell me why and I just looked
at him and I'm like pretending like I
couldn't hear him but I could totally
hear him it's like Oh half an inch of
glass and he's like hey let me in I want
to get coffee and I just had to ignore
him and then like he stood there
watching me as I was setting up the
cereal bar and he just like wraps the
mug against the window like Freddy
Krueger just like dragging it back and
forth then I have to go work the line of
scooping eggs onto his tray and he says
he's like hey you saw me why didn't you
let me in and I said I was told not to
and he said who told you and I look over
at my dining hall director and she just
like shakes her head like do not rat me
out it's your job to take the fall for
this and like it's just against policy
and he treated me like [ __ ]
for the rest of the week and he told all
of his troop did not bother cleaning up
their mess like oh my god I'll leave
your tray there
it's the helps job to pick it up like it
was the worst this man in his 40s you
know I'm telling it like I with the Boy
Scouts a lot of these adult leaders
they're not the best people some of them
are really cool some of them are just
dads who get dragged into it and they
hate their job and they had a rough time
when they were enlisted in the army and
now they're trying to like be mean to
young boys who need tough love and
that's their whole value and it's you
know it's a mixed bag it's kind of sad
got out of it - Eric we survived Hey
look at us now getting paid to lose
sleep to break down Marvel trailers hey
it did build character you know and I
learned that I never want to go work
that kind of job again and I learned
that I can tell you exactly how much a
group of potatoes weighs like I'll let
you know if it's more or less than ten
pounds you give me a stack of potatoes
I'll tell you how much it weighs well
hey this has been great that's our show
reminder that you could join our
official discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars and you
can ask us these questions directly
we're more likely to see them on our
discord than we are on Twitter in the
comments of videos can also get an audio
version of the show by subscribing to
new rock stars big question where we get
your podcasts thanks to Tommy for
joining us and stepping in we enjoyed
those great
stories my pleasure Eric always a
pleasure to get a chance to talk to you
thank you for having me and now I will
never throw a bag of potatoes at you you
can't use my tactics against me thanks
again to everyone for submitting
questions to get off some may list your
questions at our p.o box follow me at ei
vas follow Tommy and Tommy Bechtold and
follow new rock star socials subscribe
here on YouTube to get too much
information all the stuff you care about
see you next week
[Music]